SMUGNESS, AND GROUPTHINK.
HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR SEAN HANNITY.
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN HAS FRANKLY
HUMILIATED THE UNITED STATES ON
THE WORLD STAGE.
SAIGON CIRCA 1975, STEROIDS,
FORMER DEFENSE SECRETARY AND CIA
DIRECTOR LEON PANETTA RIGHTLY
CALLING IT BIDEN'S BAY OF PIGS
AND THINGS TO THE ILL-FATED
ACTIONS OF OUR DERELICT LOW
FUNCTIONING PRESIDENT IF YOU
WANT TO EVEN SAY THAT, THAT IS
SOMEWHAT CHARITABLE.
THE ABSOLUTE WORST-CASE SCENARIO
HAS BEEN PLAYING OUT BEFORE OUR
EYES, BIDEN IGNORING THE ADVICE
IN THE COUNSEL OF HIS TOP U.S.
MILITARY COMMANDERS.
WE WANT TO SLOW EVACUATION OF
U.S. TROOPS BASED ON CONDITIONS
ON THE GROUND.
IGNORE THE WARNINGS FROM OUR
INTEL ON THE GROUND AND NOW
AFGHANISTAN HAS FALLEN TO THE
ISLAMIC EXTREMISTS, THE TALIBAN
IN RECORD TIME.
THEY JUST SAID LAST WEEK IT
WOULD BE 90 DAYS AT THE EARLIEST
AND IT WAS OVERRUN IN A MATTER
OF HOURS.
TALIBAN FIGHTERS ARE NOW IN
CONTROL OF A MASSIVE STOCKPILE
OF JOE BIDEN U.S. TAXPAYER PAID
FOR WEAPONS AND AMMO, VEHICLES,
OTHER SUPPLIES ABANDONED DURING
BIDEN'S HASTY RETREAT.
IT WASN'T EVEN SMART ENOUGH TO
TAKE MUNITIONS OUT.
TERRORISTS FROM AL QAEDA AND
ISIS WERE FREED FROM MULTIPLE
PRISONS ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY,
THEY SOON WILL BE PLOTTING AND
PLANNING THEIR FUTURE TERRORIST
ATTACKS ON ALL OF THE U.S. AND
THE REST OF THE WORLD FOMENTING
TERROR.
THE AMERICAN FLAG LOWERED OVER
OUR EMBASSY BEYOND HUMILIATING
AS DIPLOMATS HASTILY WERE
EVACUATED BY HELICOPTER TO THE
AIRPORT.
THE VERY THING BIDEN SAID IT
WOULDN'T HAPPEN.
VIEWER WARNING, WE WERE ABOUT TO
SEE IS INCREDIBLY GRAPHIC BUT
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS HORRIFIC
VIDEO EARLIER TODAY, THOUSANDS
OF DESPERATE AFGHAN CITIZENS
LEANING CERTAIN DEATH AT THE
HANDS OF THE TALIBAN NOW RUSHING
TO THE TARMAC OF THE AIRPORT
TRYING TO CLING TO A DEPARTING
SEA 17 MILITARY PLANE, SOME
CRUSHED UNDER THE WHEELS OF
PLANES AND OTHERS FELL FROM THE
PLAIN MIDAIR DURING ITS ASCENT
HOPING THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO
HANG ON AND GET OUT OF THERE,
DOZENS OF OTHERS DESPERATELY
ATTEMPTING TO BOARD ANY AND ALL
COMMERCIAL PLANES PARKED ON THE
RUNWAY, AT LEAST SEVEN PEOPLE
DIED IN THE CHAOS AND TONIGHT AS
WE SPEAK, THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY 10,000 AMERICANS
THAT ARE STILL AT THE
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT
DESPERATELY ATTEMPTING TO FLEE
THE COUNTRY.
JOE, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
6,000 U.S. SOLDIERS NOW OR IN
THE PROCESS OF REGENERATING
AFGHANISTAN, TAKEN OVER BY THE
TALIBAN TO TRY TO NOT SECURE THE
AIRPORT TO TRY AND SAVE
AMERICANS.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, A COMPLETE AND
TOTAL FAILURE OF LEADERSHIP,
PLANNING, AND EXECUTION AND TRUE
TO FORM HAS A DISASTER UNFOLDED
OVER THE WEEKEND, JOE BIDEN WAS
NOWHERE TO BE FOUND.
ASIDE FROM THIS BIZARRE PHOTO
CROUCHING OVER AN EMPTY TABLE
DURING A ZOOM CALL AND WE'VE GOT
NOTHING FROM NOTHING FROM BIDEN
ALL WEEKEND WHILE THIS WAS
UNFOLDING IN REAL TIME.
HIS PRESS SECRETARY WASN'T
AVAILABLE TO CIRCLE BACK ON
ANYTHING, JEN PSAKI WAS ON
VACATION.
YOU WROTE HER, YOU GOT AN AUTO
REPLY SAYING I WILL BE OUT OF
THE OFFICE FROM AUGUST 15TH TO
THE 22ND, HOPE YOU'RE HAVING A
GREAT VACATION.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS WAS
ALSO M.I.A. BUT TODAY FINALLY,
COMES OUT OF HIDING FOR A VERY
BRIEF SCRIPTED SPEECH BY HIS
STAFF BEFORE HEADING BACK TO
VACATION WHERE HE BLAMED
EVERYONE FOR HIS CATASTROPHE BUT
HIMSELF BUT SAYS THE BUCK STOPS
WITH HIM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN I CAME INTO OFFICE, I
INHERITED A DEAL THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP NEGOTIATED WITH
A TALIBAN PIER THE CHOICE I HAD
TO MAKE AS YOUR PRESIDENT WAS
EITHER TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON THAT
AGREEMENT OR BE PREPARED TO GO
BACK TO FIGHTING THE TALIBAN.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENED?
AFGHANISTAN POLITICAL LEADERS
GAVE UP AND FLED THE COUNTRY.
THE AFGHAN MILITARY COLLAPSE
SOMETIME WITHOUT TRYING TO
FIGHT.
I KNOW THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT
WHY WE DID NOT BEGIN EVACUATING
AFGHANS CIVILIANS SOONER.
PART OF THE ANSWER IS SOME OF
THE AFGHANS DID NOT WANT TO
LEAVE EARLIER.
I AM PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND THE BUCK STOPS WITH ME.
>> Sean: BUT I BLAME EVERYBODY
ELSE.
DID HE HAVE ANY PROBLEM
OVERTURNING THE SECURE
BORDER WALL, STAY IN MEXICO,
STOP BUILDING THE WALL?
STOP CATCH AND RELEASE NOW HAS
THE PROCESS OF RELEASE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC WITHOUT
VACCINE PASSPORTS, VACCINE
MANDATES, MASK MANDATES AND
SENDING PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY SAME WITH ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, TOOK US AWAY FROM
THAT, HAS NO PROBLEM CHANGING
POLICIES ON EVERYTHING.
TO RECAP, BIDEN BLAMED THE
AFGHAN PEOPLE IN THE AFGHAN
MILITARY AND THE AFGHAN
PRESIDENT, THE AFGHAN
GOVERNMENT, AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHEN ALL ELSE FAILS BECAUSE
LAUGHABLY CLAIMING THE BUCK
STOPS WITH HIM PRETTY SPINELESS
AND COWARDLY.
OF COURSE, BIDEN TOOK ZERO
QUESTIONS FOLLOWING THOSE
REMARKS.
I'M SURE HE HAS BEEN EXHAUSTED
WITH TOO MUCH WORK, A WHOLE
20 MINUTES AND IMMEDIATELY
RETURNED TO HIS VACATION FOR
MORE R&R AND ICE CREAM WITH
SPRINKLES ON IT.
BUT LET'S BE HONEST, THE SPEECH
WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED TODAY IF
NOT FOR THE IMMENSE BLOWBACK
FROM PRETTY MUCH ANYONE WITH
HALF A BRAIN, EVEN JOE'S
PROTECTORS IN THE MEDIA MOB
COULD NOT IGNORE THE FULL
DISASTER THAT THIS IS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HOW DOES THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MISCALCULATE THIS
INTELLIGENCE SO GRAVELY?
>> THIS IS A FIASCO, A BIG PART
OF LIFE'S EXECUTION AND
IMPLEMENTATION AND THIS IS JUST
MALPRACTICE, THIS HAS BEEN A
FIASCO BY ANY AND EVERY MEASURE.
>> THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE
OVERALL IDEA OF LEAVING
AFGHANISTAN, THIS IS ABOUT
LEAVING HASTILY AND INEPTLY.
HOW DID PRESIDENT BIDEN GET THIS
SO WRONG?
>> THEY ARE CALLING THIS
WITHDRAWAL OF FIASCO, A DEBACLE
AND IT IS ONE THAT APPARENTLY
THE ADMINISTRATION DID NOT FULLY
APPRECIATE OR SEE COMING.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS WRONG ABOUT THE
LENGTH OF TIME THEY HAD, WRONG
ABOUT THE STRENGTH OF THE AFGHAN
MILITARY, WRONG ABOUT THE REACH
OF THE TALIBAN.
>> IN SO MANY WAYS, THIS IS
COMPLETELY ON PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> Sean: TO SUM UP, JOE BIDEN
DID EVERYTHING WRONG.
JUST ONE MONTH AGO, HE WAS
ASSURING US THAT A TALIBAN
TAKEOVER WAS NOT INEVITABLE AT
ALL BECAUSE THEY HAD SUCH A
STRONG ARMY AND AIR FORCE AND
EVERYTHING AND IT WAS HUNDRED
THOUSAND WELL-TRAINED MY SOME OF
THE BEST TRAINED SOLDIERS IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD AND ONLY 75,000
TALIBAN.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE DON'T HAVE TO BE TAKING
PEOPLE OUT IN HELICOPTERS AT THE
LAST MINUTE, WON'T HAVE PEOPLE
RACING OUT OF THERE.
WRONG AGAIN.
>> IT WAS A TALIBAN TAKEOVER OF
AFGHANISTAN INEVITABLE?
>> NO, IT IS NOT.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE AFGHAN
TROOPS AT 300,000 WELL-EQUIPPED
AS ANY ARMY IN THE WORLD AND
AIR FORCE AGAINST SOMETHING LIKE
25,000 TALIBAN.
IT IS NOT INEVITABLE.
THERE'S GOING TO BE NO
CIRCUMSTANCE YOU SEE PEOPLE
BEING LIFTED OFF THE ROOF OF AN
EMBASSY OF THE UNITED STATES
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
>> Sean: 300,000 WELL-EQUIPPED
AND THEY HAVE AN AIR FORCE AS
GOOD AS ANY MILITARY ON THE FACE
OF THE EARTH.
THE EXACT OPPOSITE HAPPENED,
JOE.
THESE ARE THE IMAGES OF PEOPLE
BEING LIFTED OFF THE ROOF OF OUR
EMBASSY OVER THE WEEKEND.
WHEN YOU SAID IT WOULDN'T
HAPPEN, YOUR SIDE GONE AND YOUR
BAY OF PIGS AND IT GETS WORSE.
IN JUNE, BIDEN SECRETARY OF
STATE IS A TOTAL IDIOT, TONY
BLINKEN, THE GUY THAT SUCKED UP
TO CHINA AND TOOK LECTURES ON
HUMAN RIGHTS FROM THEM AS THE
CHINESE ARE NOW THREATENING OUR
MILITARY BASES DAY IN AND DAY
OUT PROCLAIMED IT A QUICK
TALIBAN TAKEOVER WAS NOT
POSSIBLE.
>> WE ARE NOT WITHDRAWING, WE
ARE STAYING, THE EMBASSY IS
STAYING, OUR PROGRAMS ARE
STAYING IN WHATEVER HAPPENS IN
AFGHANISTAN IF THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT DETERIORATION COULD
HAPPEN.
WE DISCUSSED THIS BEFORE, I
DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS FROM
FRIDAY TO MONDAY SO I WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY EQUATE THE DEPARTURE
OF OUR FORCES IN JULY, AUGUST,
OR BY EARLY SEPTEMBER WITH HIM
KIND OF IMMEDIATE DETERIORATION.
>> Sean: NUMBER ONE, YOU LIED.
NUMBER TWO, PEOPLE WILL DIE.
NUMBER THREE, YOU ARMED THE
TALIBAN AND YOU NEED TO BE
FIRED, NUMBER FOUR.
THE EXACT OPPOSITE HAPPENED.
NOW MANY ARE CALLING THE ILL
PLANNED RETREAT IN SAIGON, BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTUALLY
BEGGING THE TALIBAN TERRORIST,
PLEASE ALLOW AMERICANS TO SAFELY
LEAVE THE COUNTRY TWO DECADES
AFTER 9/11.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THIS IS ABOUT
SO MUCH MORE THAN JUST
AFGHANISTAN.
THE WORLD IS WATCHING, OUR
ALLIES AND ENEMIES ALIKE ARE
WITNESSING JOE BIDEN'S PATHETIC
WEAKNESS ON THE WORLD STAGE.
IT IS HUMILIATING AND
EMBARRASSING FOR THIS COUNTRY
NOW ONE OF CHINA'S TOP
NEWSPAPERS ARE PREDICTING THAT
AMERICA WILL ABANDON TAIWAN JUST
LIKE THEY DID AFGHANISTAN AND
NOW OPENLY PLANNING A TOTAL
REUNIFICATION.
LET ME INTERPRET THAT FOR YOU,
THAT MEANS A TAKEOVER OF TAIWAN
AND MEANWHILE, RUSSIA DOESN'T
FEAR US EITHER WITH ALL OF THEIR
CYBERATTACKS OR THEY DON'T
RESPECT US AS WELL AND THEY ARE
NOW SUPPLYING ALL THE ENERGY FOR
ALL OF OUR WESTERN AND EUROPEAN
ALLIES BECAUSE HE LET IT HAPPEN
AND GRANTED HIM A WAIVER WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY FIRING AMERICAN
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE WORKERS.
GREAT JOB, JOE.
AND THEN JOE GIFTED THEM WITH A
NEW PIPELINE, THE U.S. HAS NOW
ENDURED A NEVER ENDING STREAM OF
RUSSIAN CYBERATTACKS.
AND IRAN, NOW CONTINUING TO
ENRICH URANIUM AT AN ACCELERATED
AND OF COURSE, JOE HAD THE
SOUTH KOREANS GIVE IRAN
$7 BILLION HE WENT AFTER JOE
ATTEMPTED TO BRIBE THEM WITH
MORE INTERNATIONAL CURRENCY.
IN AFGHANISTAN, WE HAVE AL QAEDA
SAFE HAVEN BACK STANDING ON THE
WORLD STAGE NOW AMERICANS
EVERYWHERE ARE LESS SAFE AND
LESS SECURE AS THEY PLOT, PLAN,
AND SCHEME THEIR NEXT 9/11
ATTACK ON AMERICA.
ROBERT GATES WROTE THAT BIDEN
HAD BEEN WRONG ON NEARLY EVERY
SINGLE MAJOR FOREIGN POLICY AND
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE OVER THE
PAST FOUR DECADES.
REMEMBER, HE DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE
OUT BIN LADEN AND ACCORDING TO
POLITICAL, BIDEN'S FORMER BOSS
PRESIDENT OBAMA EVEN EXPRESSED A
SIMILAR LEVEL OF CONCERN TELLING
A FELLOW DEMOCRAT "DON'T
UNDERESTIMATE JOE'S ABILITY TO
[BLEEP] THINGS UP."
THIS IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
JOE BIDEN AND DONALD TRUMP.
FOR ALL THE SNOWFLAKES OUT THERE
THAT GET THE VAPORS EVERY TIME
DONALD TRUMP SENSE OUT A MEAN
TWEET AND EVERYTHING.
THEY FEAR TRUMP.
THE WORLD FOR YOUR.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP GAVE A THREAT,
THEY BELIEVED HIM.
BIDEN THEY KNOW IS WEAK AND NOT
RUNNING THE SHOW.
THE WORLD SEES IT NOT INFLUENCED
BY AMERICA'S MEDIA MOB AND
PROPAGANDA OUTLETS.
AMERICA AND THE WORLD DESERVES
BETTER.
THE WORLD NEEDS A STRON